TACTICAL GROUND MISSILES, AND IT
WAS A BIG OPERATION.
WHERE DOES THIS GO FROM HERE?
IN THIS PROXY WAR, IF YOU WILL?
WE WILL BRING IN THE PANEL,
STEVE HILTON, FORMER ADVISER,
AND HOST OF "NEXT REVOLUTION"
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
GEORGETOWN INSTITUTE OF
POLITICS.
AND BYRON YORK, POLITICIAN OF
THE EXAMINER.
IT DID NOT GET A TON OF
COVERAGE, BUT I THINK THAT THE
PROSPECT OF THIS BECOMING A
MAJOR THING IN THE MIDDLE EAST
COULD BE BIG.
>> AND THE QUESTION IS THAT WHAT
DOES IT HAVE TO DO WITH WHAT HAS
JUST HAPPENED AND WITH THE IRAN
DEAL, AND CLEARLY IRAN AND
ISRAEL HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING A
SHADOW WAR IN THE AREA FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
AND IT HAS BEEN GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE AND WORSE.
WHAT WE ARE STRIKING IS THE
REACTION OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, A VERY, VERY
STRONG MESSAGE IN SUPPORT OF
ISRAEL, NOT ONLY AFFIRMING
ISRAEL'S SUPPORTING GOING
FIGHTING BACK, BUT IT'S RIGHT TO
FIGHT BACK AND DEFEND ITSELF.
SO I THINK THAT WE SAW, ALSO
JUST A SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS
SOUND BITES THAT WE HEARD, WE
HAVE HEARD A VERY DIFFERENT
MESSAGE I DID THIS WHITE HOUSE
AND THE PREVIOUS ONE.
>> Bret: AND THE WAKE OF THE DEA
>> Bret: AND THE WAKE OF THE DEL
IS THE PROSPECT THAT IS
GREATER.
>> YES, THAT'S WHERE THE
EUROPEAN ALLIES WERE WORRIED
ABOUT, I AGREE, THERE IS BEEN
THERE SHADOW WAR THAT IS BEING
FOUGHT, AND TWO THERE WAS A LOT
OF CONCERN FROM EUROPEAN ALLIES
THAT BY WALKING AWAY FROM THE
DEAL, IT MIGHT STOKE TENSIONS
JUST ENOUGH TO MAKE THAT SHADOW
WAR BUBBLE UP INTO THE SURFACE
AND MAKE IT MORE INTENSE.
I DO NOT THINK ANYONE QUESTIONS
ISRAEL'S RIGHT TO DEFEND ITSELF.
I THINK THAT WE ALL STAND WITH
ISRAEL.
BUT YOU KNOW, YOU HEARD FROM OUR
EUROPEAN ALLIES TODAY, CALLS,
PLEASE, FOR A LEVEL OF MEASURED
RESPONSE.
THAT WE DO NOT ALLOW THIS THING
TO ESCALATE AS IT SO EASILY
COULD.
AND TRY TO BRING EVERYONE BACK
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE TO FIND
A NEW DEAL.
>> Bret: ON THE FLIP SIDE, THE
IRAN DEAL, IT WAS NOT SPENDING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, FILLING
THE POT HOLES, THEY WERE
OBVIOUSLY INVESTING IN MILITARY
OPERATIONS IN SYRIA, AND FUNDING
HAS GONE AWAY WITHOUT MONEY.
>> YOU COULD NOT ASK FOR BETTER
JUSTIFICATION WITH WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DID WITH THE IRAN
DEAL, IT PROVES THE POINT THAT
ACTUALLY IRAN IS AN AGGRESSIVE
WARMONGERING REGIME AND WANTS TO
CONTROL THE WHOLE REGION FOR A
LONG TIME NOW.
THE POLICY OF THE U.S. AND THE
EUROPEAN ALLIES HAS BEEN
APPEASEMENT, ESSENTIALLY, IF WE
TALK TO YOU WHEN WE GIVE YOU
MONEY AND WE SUPPORT YOU, THERE
MAY BE YOU WILL CHANGE YOUR
WAYS, THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED.
AND SO NOW WE ARE IN THE NEW
WORLD WHERE THE POLICY IS TO
STAND UP TO THE BULLY AND
CONFRONT THE BULLY, AND THAT IS
NOT COMFORTABLE.
IT IS NOT EASY.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THE ALLIES
ARE GETTING NERVOUS, BUT THAT
HER POLICY HAS FAILED TO CONTAIN
IRAN.
>> THEY ARE ALSO NOT THE ONLY
ALLIES IN THE WHOLE WORLD TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
THERE ARE THE EGYPTIANS, THE
SAUDIS, AND THERE ARE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WHO HAVE A
BIG STAKE IN THIS.
I THINK THAT THEY SUPPORT WHAT
THE UNITED STATES IS DOING.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
BIG MOMENT OVERNIGHT, WE HAVE
COVERED IT, THE THREE AMERICANS
COMING HOME FROM NORTH KOREA.
AND THE QUESTION WAS, WHO GETS
CREDIT?
AND HOW MUCH NORTH KOREA CREDIT
IS THERE NOW THAT THE SUMMIT IS
SET IN PLACE, HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT AND THE MINORITY
LEADER.
>> WE WANT TO THANK KIM JONG UN
FOR REALLY, IT WAS EXCELLENT,
TAKING THESE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
>> THE EXULTATION BY THE
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS WITH
NORTH KOREA DOING THIS.
IT EVADES ME.
WE CANNOT BE FOOLED INTO GIVING
THE NORTH KOREAN REGIME CREDIT
FOR RETURNING AMERICANS THAT
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN DETAINED
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE NOT
DIPLOMATIC BARGAINING CHIPS.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THAT,
STEVE?
>> THIS REMINDS ME SO MUCH OF
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL MISTAKES
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CRITICS MAKE OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THEY FOCUS ALMOST ENTIRELY ON
HIS WORDS, HIS PERFORMANCE,
ALMOST LIKE TV CRITICS RATHER
THAN POLITICAL ANALYSTS.
THEY IGNORE THE SUBSTANCE.
SOMETIMES HE SAYS WORDS THAT
WOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED
DIPLOMATIC IN THE NORMAL
PARLANCE OF POLITICS, BUT HE
GETS THE RESULTS.
AND THEY FOCUS ON THE
SUPERFICIAL.
AND EIGHT IGNORE THE FACT THAT
HE IS ACTUALLY MAKING REAL
PROGRESS.
>> IT IS WAY TOO EARLY TO KNOW
WHETHER HE IS MAKING PROGRESS ON
NORTH KOREA.
THE NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR SEIZED
AMERICAN CITIZENS, TWO OF WHICH
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION, THIS
PRESIDENT.
AND RETURN THEM TODAY, JUST AS
WE ARE ABOUT TO HEAD INTO A
SUMMIT.
I AM HOPEFUL, AND THE DEMOCRATS,
BUT I AM HOPEFUL THAT OUR
PRESIDENT IS SUCCESSFUL IN THE
SUMMIT.
BUT THERE ARE MANY FLAGS HERE.
THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND THAT THIS NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR IS LOOKING TO BE SEEN
AS AN EQUAL OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE COMMENTS THAT HE HAS BEEN
MAKING, IT ISN'T ABOUT, HE IS
PROMISING TO STOP NUCLEAR
TESTING, WHY?
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES THAT THE
NUCLEAR TESTS ARE ALREADY
SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH.
HE SAYS THE TOTAL
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA, THAT MEANS THE
UNITED STATES TOO.
I HOPE THAT THE PRESIDENT CAN
GO.
AND IF HE CAN NEGOTIATE
SOMETHING SUCCESSFUL, I WILL BE
AMONG THE FIRST TO APPLAUD HIM.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF RED
FLAGS.
AND I WORRY, I WORRIED THAT THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR'S ARE
PLAYING A LITTLE BIT.
>> Bret: WE OBVIOUSLY DO NOT
KNOW THE DETAILS, AND THE DEVIL
WILL BE ON THE DETAILS, BUT A
MONTH AGO, A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
SAYING THAT WE ARE HEADING TO
WAR WITH NORTH KOREA.
TO SPEAK OF THE JUNE 12TH IN
SINGAPORE MEANS THAT IT IS MORE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN, A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT HOW IT WOULD NOT HAPPEN,
BUT CAN WE JUST SAY THAT THE REL
BUT CAN WE JUST SAY THAT THE REA
BUT CAN WE JUST SAY THAT THE REE
BUT CAN WE JUST SAY THAT THE REO
BUT CAN WE JUST SAY THAT THE REF
THE THREE AMERICANS IS GREAT
NEWS.
IT IS GOOD NEWS FOR THEM AND
GOOD NEWS FOR THE UNITED STATES.
AND IT IS GOOD NEWS FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
SO EVEN, AND IT IS NOT
CONDITIONAL ON THE SUCCESS OF
THE NORTH KOREAN TALKS IF THEY
DO NOT SUCCEED, JUST LIKE THEY